c'est moi dès que je suis en flirt avec
une meuf ouais j'emploie des mots des
années 80 d'arrêter seconde adaptation
[Musique]
le vanguard quatrième à huit mais alors
on développe t a l'air un peu ma griffe
et de ouf je sers des griffes et que mon
petit doigt m'a fouetté la gueule quoi
[Musique]
je fais de vent c'était parfait bonjour
je suis sam adams
[Musique]
s'allume quand j'ai tout raconté la
femme quoi va terminer on enregistre
normalement c'est le même plan de jeu tu
me faisais le briançonnais
il monte un peu sur la [ __ ] ce truc je
crois dégouline un peu c'est dégueulasse
est devenu brillant notamment la meuf 1%
lois françaises
ainsi qu un max de lubrifiants
extrêmement mal joué tombera c'est mon
frère qui est détruit c'est dégueulasse
au japon ouais surtout ce qu'ils
annulation comme la mienne immeuble
porté par tout cas peut-être qu'elle
vaut plus achète un immeuble
peut-être qu'elle prenait quelqu'un
votre homosexuels
[Musique]
depuis dallas dit que je peux d'ailleurs
leur sens que je peux y aller tout le
temps c'est à vous regarder comme ça je
ne m'en fait c'est dur de te maintenir
parce que tu es vraiment musclée en fait
à aller en force avant j'étais pas oui
ouais on en réalise a dit que c'était
musclé si vous mettez toute ma force
c'est un peu douves soul
[Musique]
non mais là si je veux à temps non mais
là j'ai pas mis tout mon temps à temps
mais là je m'égare n'ont pas laissé
faire détruits c'est bien c'est réaliste
comme ça
osmani qui m'en a envoyé une petite
carte avec un petit chaton trop mignon
ça dommageable des pâtes cheikh ya pas
de cheikh bamba des fouilles alors kano
dessus pour moi